so there was a question from someone
that wanted to know when not to take
bile salts is there any
contraindications so I wanted to create
this video for that person first of all
most people need bile salts and usually
they're not producing enough bile salts
are made by the liver and they're stored
in the gallbladder and when the
gallbladder stores the bile salts it
concentrates them up to 20 times so it's
a super concentrated mixture to help
break down fats so you can extract the
fat soluble vitamins and the essential
fatty acids from the food that you eat
the pancreas releases lipase and enzyme
to break down fats and then it'll
actually help to dissolve this fat into
the small particles so you can utilize
the nutrients from the fat so we make
about a quart of bile every single day
and 90 percent of the bile is recycled
through the small intestine bile is also
necessary to help a person detoxify
chemicals from the liver and out through
the body and it's a very important
compound and you can also take purified
bowel salts to help you with the
digestion of fats and also to prevent
the formation of gall stones because
gall stones come from a deficiency of
bile salts but there's certain
situations where you wouldn't want to
take them number one if you had diarrhea
why well because purified bile salts
help to retain fluid in the colon and
they help to lubricate food going
through the colon so if you have
diarrhea and you take purified bath
salts guess what you're gonna get more
diarrhea so you don't want to do that
number two hyperthyroid the liver and
the bile salts help in the conversion of
t4 to t3
eighty percent of this conversion
happens to the liver and 20% happens to
the kidney so if your thyroid is already
making too much of the active form of
thyroid hormone which is t3 and you add
more bile salts and make more t3 you're
gonna make it worse so you don't want to
recommend bile salts to anyone with a
hyper thyroid state
but on the flip side if you have a
hypothyroid condition you would want to
take it because it's gonna help you
convert from t4 to t3 in fact it could
be the reason why your thyroid is slow
in the first place
third reason why you wouldn't want to
take purified bile salts is that if you
have some type of bile malabsorption
problem now that could be caused because
your intestines are not absorbing the
bile salts because you have Crohn's
disease which is inflammatory condition
or celiac which is another inflammatory
condition or small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth which will mess up the
balance of bile and there's other
conditions as well so because purified
bile salts gets recycled and you also
need help by your microbes if you have a
problem with either one and this file is
concentrating you don't want to take
more now some people have the
gallbladder removed have a situation
where there's too much bile because the
tube is maybe too large and it's just
draining right into the small intestine
in that case they're usually going to
have diarrhea and your doctor will
recommend a bile acid binder and here's
one medication that they use but there's
many more you can check with your doctor
on that but it's a way to inhibit or
slow down the bile in your body but the
problem with that it comes with certain
side effects because now you're gonna
have the inability to absorb certain
fats I above items will like vitamin A D
and K because you're binding these bile
salts but if your body is making too
much bile or you have too much bile
realize that the trigger for bile
production is saturated fats so one
thing you're probably going to want to
do is lower the amount of fats in your
diet to about 60 grams per day not any
lower than that
because you need the fats but if you
have too much bile in the first place
you don't want to start triggering more
about adding more saturated fats alright
there you have it
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next video so if you want more
knowledge on how to create a healthy
body subscribe now and get daily
notifications